Hey everyone. This is Shaun. I’m the assistant
instructor for web applications engineering.
Peter unfortunately couldn’t be here because he
is off doing something silly like graduating. So
you’re stuck with me.
So let’s just jump right into the home work
solutions. First question was about interpreting,
testing, debugging. Actually all the homeworks
are about that. And this question starts off with
just a quiz, first off embedded JavaScript
programs use functions like document.write to
change the surrounding web page. Yes, this is true.
We can take a quick look at something like this.
So I’ve loaded up this HTML into a file and you
can see there is a bit of java script in the
script tag here, just a simple factorial function.
And then it uses the document.write method to
write out the factorial five, which is 120 and
then write out the expression five is equal to
five. So this should write out 120 and then
true. So if we load this up in our web browser,
we see that at the end of this, it has modified the
web page to write 120 and true. Now we haven’t
done any kind of styling to this, so it’s just
running right into each other. But the point
remains is that the document.write function is
really how you modify on a basic level the
overwriting HTML page.
Next part, testing can prove that a web browser
is correct. That is not true. So we can take a
look at an example of that too. So let’s say I
have a basic square function. Well actually not a
basic square function, it’s much more
complicated than it needs to be. But let’s see
about if we can prove this is true with some test
cases. So let’s print out some test cases say print
square three and this if you run it, okay that
brings out nine that makes sense. But then if we
print out another test case and we see this is 9-2,
which is what we expect. So I am just going to
print out a few more test cases, okay. We’ve got
a few more test cases here and we can already
tell the square of 0 should be 0. And the square
of two should be 4. So go ahead and run these
and we get the expected output. Now are we
done here, are we proved that this is correct?
Obviously not because if you look at the code,
this isn’t going to return the square of X for
anything that is were mod two equals 0 and X is
not two. Works fine for X as two. But when we
print out square four which should be 16, but we
instead get is 8, which is not at all what we want.
So testing is great. Having simple small unit
tests is a good habit to get into. But you can’t
really test for every single possible input. It’s
just not feasible. So you should be prepared for
accepting that your code is probably right. But
you can’t guarantee it with testing, okay. And
the third part program should compute different
answers before and after it has been optimized.
Now this is definitely not true.
Program should be correct.
Now what correct is, it can vary depending on
what your actual goals are, but the program
should work as you intend it and once you start
optimizing things that shouldn’t change. Now
the final part of this quiz is making changes to a
test case can help to localize a program bug.
And yes, this is true. And we can see an
example of this. This is actually fairly similar to
what we were doing for. So you got an absolute
value function and let’s say I’ve already told
you that something is wrong with it. And I want
you to find where the bug is. Well, where do we start?
Well, let’s try printing out, the absolute
value of one because we’re trying to break down
on what part, what branch of this function, the
bug that I’ve already you about is in. So we
want to differentiate between positive values
and negative values and zero, is that breaks it
down to one of these two, statements. And we
get out one which is the absolute value of one.
So, okay that seems okay. Now let’s try and
narrow it down a bit further from there.
Okay, so let’s narrow it down a bit further and
now let’s do the absolute value of 8, which is
still right here. It’s still going to be in this else
statement, but since it’s greater than two, it’s
going to go into this internal if statement instead
of this other else. So when we’re on this, we get
0, not 8. So we see that the bug is in this and its
fairly clear that that’s where it is and most
programs that you’re debugging this is not
going to be this simple, but you can add
additional test cases and use your test cases to
narrow down on what part of your function, the
errors are in. And that’s really the
point of this, right here.